you're making a hundred thousand dollars
a year the first person you should be
hiring is the person who can replace the
most of your time that you're actively
doing and so right now if you're making
100 grand it's probably because you have
a lot of fulfillment delivering client
services or delivering products to
customers that piece should probably be
the first piece the second piece would
probably be all the administrative work
because that's not really value ad it's
just stuff that has to happen in the
background and you need to be driving
sales and focusing on promoting the
product for an operational helper you
can get a va for a few bucks an hour in
terms of delivery hub you can also get a
va for a few bucks an hour depending on
the type of work and so i highly
recommend outsourcing especially if
you're starting because it's lower risk
and believe it or not those people will
be excited to work for you they'll show
up on time because they're going to
support their entire family with that
wage rather than some entitled 17 year
old